BurpSuite Enterprise Edition's bulk site upload feature makes it easier for you to add a large
number of sites to the system. When uploading sites in bulk, you first need to prepare a CSV
template with the site information, which you can then upload to BurpSuite Enterprise. To help you,
we provide a sample template that you can edit. Please note you can add as many sites as you need
at no extra cost. BurpSuite Enterprise Edition licensing is based on the number of concurrent
scans you can run, not the number of sites added to the system. To begin, we need to prepare the
import CSV file. If we navigate to our sites page and select the import sites button, we can download
the CSV template. If we open up the template, we can then add our sites to the template in the same
format as the example. So we have site name, included URLs, excluded URLs, scanning pool name,
scan configuration, email recipients. We can see if a field is mandatory, how it needs to be formatted,
or we can leave defaults. Once you've populated all of your sites with the required information,
simply delete the first three entries, leaving just your own unique sites. We can return to BurpSuite
Enterprise, select our file and import the CSV. At this stage, we can also add our sites to the
existing folder structure if we have created it. Once we select import, the sites will be imported
and they'll be present within BurpSuite Enterprise Edition. Thank you.